[Music]
let's go out to Baltimore and talk to
Denise what's up
Denise hi Dr deloney how are you I'm I I
don't know after that last call I'm
still trying to figure out what day it
is so how are
you I'm doing okay thank you for taking
my call it's such an honor to talk to
you I'm a big fan of you and the the
whole Ramsey team and I really respect
the the advice and the truth that I hear
you delve out to others just like on
that last call
so to talk to you I don't know how much
I helped on that last call but so what's
up what's
up so I really reached out because I'm
looking for some help in um dealing with
something see my husband and I he
recently had a DUI incident hey do me a
favor talk directly into your phone for
me oh can you hear me better now I'm
sorry yeah that's much better all right
um so yeah he recently had a DUI
incident okay he had been drinking with
friends and got involved in in an
accident where luckily no one was hurt
but he did hit another parked car um and
just was not a not a good situation and
his drinking in general and drinking and
driving has been kind of a you know an
ongoing issue for I would say the past
least probably three to five years or
more um but his luck just kind of
finally ran out and it kind of came to a
head when this happened and we've had
you know lots of arguments and
discussions where I've tried to stress
to him that if he didn't make some
serious changes there were going to be
some consequences to his actions and
that's what has happened so um there's a
chance he could go to jail I know
there's probably going to be some some
significant fines and legal fees and
other things that are going to be a
burden to us
and I just I'm struggling with how to
deal with it um he is very ashamed um
and regrets the whole thing um I think
that it has been a wakeup call for him
he says he's completely done with
drinking all together doesn't want any
alcohol at all um but I'm just really do
you
I I want to I don't think you I don't
think you would be calling me if you
believed him yeah just because you know
it nothing like this has ever happened
before um you know this serious but he
has absolutely said that before that he
you know he can he doesn't have a
problem he can manage it himself um but
yeah he I I don't know how to to trust
him and believe that he really does want
to stop drinking so here's the thing the
DUI if he quits drinking and cleans
himself up be the luckiest thing that
ever happened to him nobody got hurt
it's going to cost him a you you think
you know how expensive this is going to
be it will
be it will be astounding how expensive
this is okay and good good I'm glad it
is it should be more expensive I got I
got zero none zero sympathy for people
who get DUIs period zero ever ever um
but it comes with it right he he mouthed
off to a bullying up punch in the nose
that's what happens right so that's not
why you're
calling you're calling because you're
married to somebody who has heard you
speak your
heart and has said I don't
care I don't care how you feel I don't
care what you want I don't care what you
need I'm just gonna do my thing that's
the issue
here
the a secondary component is those
things could kill somebody else and it
could have he just hit a parked car like
an
idiot yeah right yep and so what you
have to deal with the DUI is the DUI man
he got he's gonna get arrested have to
go into the legal system he's going to
have to report that on every job he ever
has unless he gets an attorney that
pleads it down for him it's going to
cost
him unfathomable about of money um that
y'all probably don't have that that's
all part of the consequences but even
the way you say that to him you sound
like a mom talking to a little
boy not a wife cuz here's what a wife
says a mom says if you keep doing that
there's going to be
consequences a wife says I think
enough about I I have respect and
dignity for myself
enough that if you put yourself or me or
other innocent people in this
position right I'm
out yeah here's the quote unquote in
counseling we call it the or what you
can't put up a
boundary or hold somebody accountable
without an or what statement you got to
quit drinking or
what well I mean not really anything I'm
just going to like nag you or you got to
quit drinking and driving okay or what
like uh I'm I don't know
like so I'll ask you what's your or what
statement because here and here's why
that's important I want you to think
through it
if there's no or what statement what
you're saying to yourself is I've made
peace that this is my
life and if that's what you've made
peace with then that's what you've made
peace
with otherwise no it's not are you done
I mean tell me what your or what
statement is no well we've we have had
that discussion since this incident
happened and and what I said to him and
I actually even said it not too long
before um but I told him if you he
continues down this path of putting
himself and other people at risk I can't
continue to live that way I can't
continue to live with somebody that I
can't
trust um and that doesn't have like you
said doesn't have any respect and value
you know our lives and what we've built
together and is just willing to throw it
all away because he wants to drink I
just can't so the the one and I'm super
proud of you for saying that that's hard
right that's hard especially if he's
truly not just being a moronic bro but
he's struggling with alcohol there's
things in his life that his body has
said hey Guy this is the best way we
need to uh we can get through a day for
right
now that he is drowning in his own life
and alcohol is his Lifeline like man I
got a lot of uh sympathy for I got a lot
of broken heart for that dude if that's
if that's what's truly happening or if
he's just like a reckless idiot and he's
like yeah bro like then man we got
that's other problem but I'm proud of
you for saying that here's the one cavat
that you have to add this
time you left it very very
vague if you keep putting other people
at risk and having the see what I'm
saying and that leaves to a judgment
call especially a judgment call after a
dude's had four doubles and a couple of
beers I'm not putting anybody at risk
I'm going to be fine so where your or
what statement has to get clear it has
to get very
specific right if you have a single
drink and get behind the wheel of a car
again I'm filing for divorce are we
clear you're just going to leave me like
that no no no it has nothing to do with
that I've repeatedly told you what I
need from you and you've repeatedly said
those dudes These Bars this drink is
more important than you behavior is a l
right I don't think I've said it that
clearly to him but I have said I would
rather be alone than be in the situation
and again I'd rather be alone is super
it's hard to say but it's very vague
yeah I will you will be moved out of our
home right right I mean that's the kind
of
clarity otherwise it's going to always
be this amorphic kind of moving in you
know okay yeah and that's kind of what
it's become until Wham he hit somebody
thank God there was nobody in the
car yeah that's hard to hear and it will
be hard to say but I will I don't after
23 years of being married I don't want
to to see that come to an end
but can I say something SC kind of
scary yeah it's not
you this is the the not by your hand but
in your lap of course you don't want it
to end and if you sent papers to him
today that would not be you ending the
marriage he will have made a bunch of
choices he will have slammed the door in
your
face and you will be choosing to turn
around and go the other
way it's not you slamming the door on
him and that's how he'll paint it that's
how his attorney will paint it that's
how all his friends will paint it he
will have slammed the door in your face
and you will have chosen for the first
time in 23 years not just to stand there
on the porch knocking and see if he'll
open it
again right and I think that's some of
the emotion that I'm dealing with
because I have some you know some guilt
around could I have pushed him harder
and you know laid out an ultimate them
like you're saying or you know no this
Denise this is hard man this is
hard and when the good times are good
they're really good aren't
they yes and you love this guy right yes
I love him with my heart right and part
of you thinks if I'm not here to
help he's going to go so far off the
deep and we're all going to lose him
right yes I totally get that and the
scariest part for you is you can't make
him do
anything right he has to decide my worth
my life is worth more than than what I'm
what I'm what I'm living right
now right
and he can announce to the world I'm
done I'm done I'm done unless he's in a
treatment plan unless he's at a 12-step
meeting I don't I don't trust that
sentence as far as I can throw it unless
he's not seeing seeing a professional
counselor I don't trust that as far as I
can see
it that's just I've just worked with
people struggling with addiction my
whole
career right and he is you know going
down that path he's um of course I was
recommended by the attorney we talked to
is you know starting treatment he has an
appointment coming up later this week um
is going to be in an ongoing treatment
program um so that's a positive so well
here's what here's where I think your
Clarity needs to to come into I can't
I'm going to give you some some example
prompts but this is not me telling you
what to do okay right I don't want to
confuse the two you've got to
decide but based on what you're telling
me I would have a conversation today or
tomorrow that says hey I haven't been
super
clear and all of this got very clear for
me when you almost died or when you
could have killed somebody so for the
sake of both of us and for me to show
you and prove to you how much I love you
I'm going to be super clear because the
clearer I can be is demonstrative in how
much I love you here's clear if you skip
this meeting you will move out of our
house
if you skip your first counseling
meeting and don't continue to go you
will be telling me through your actions
our marriage is
over y because I think in some ways it
would be
unfair for him to skip this meeting and
you to get all mad at him and he would
look at you and go you've always told me
you're I can't do this and you're going
to leave and not going to live like this
but you've never done
anything well now being
clear if you have a single drink and
decide to drive you're telling me I
don't want to be married to you
anymore and I'll react
accordingly yep and you could tell them
I hope to all that is Holy you don't
make that choice that you let me come
get you that you get an Uber that
whatever but I think it feels like it's
all about the DUI and it's going to be
embarrassing you're going to have to
tell your friends it's going to be this
and that it's going to cost a bunch of
money again like I've said that several
times it's not about that it's about hey
you almost lost your husband I remember
when I was in a totle of my car on the
way to work um it was about a year and a
half ago now and I was doing Wim Hoff
breathing in my car like an absolute
and I total it on the highway here
out here in Nashville my wife got in a
car and drove up here and hugged me she
said I have to I have to see you and I
have to touch you and she saw me in the
parking lot I went out to meet her and
she started weeping in the parking lot
that's you you almost lost him thank God
you
didn't You' been with him a quarter
Century he's a part of you and you're
having to live
with this man has
not decided that his life is worth more
than the way he's living it and that
breaks your heart and that forces you to
make some hard
choices boundaries have to be very very
clear you want to over boundary things
to where you end up having to like
somebody calls your
bluff but I think this is boundary time
this is accountability time this is
direct time and if you choose hey I'm
never going to leave this guy I will
never ever leave him okay then don't put
that on the
table but also don't get don't get
worked up every time he does something
like
this you can be sad that he's that he's
not that he's hurting but you can't be
sad that he did it to you cuz you've
already decid I've accepted this but
doesn't sound like you're there anymore
sounds like you're
through wondering every single night is
my husband going to come home drunk is
he going to come home at
all is he goingon to sit by me on the
couch and be right next to me but not
really be fully there tired I'm just
tired of his
life we both deserve more and if you're
thinking that you're right thanks for
the call Denise wish you guys all the
best